[Music]
tiana taylor
wins at the 2017 video music awards for
her
sexy choreography in kanye west's fade
music video
e.t spoke to the star on the red carpet
before taking home her moon man trophy
i feel a little nervous though why
because
i mean anybody would you know being
nominated and
you know just a little jitters but
you're here you've been
this isn't new to you this game is not
new to you
i know but every accomplishment is gonna
always feel new you know and being
recognized for uh your hard work you
know it's always a new feeling so you
can always feel
new all of us women at home are sitting
there like
what does she do when can i get into
whatever gym she's doing how do i get
what she's doing so tell us please tell
us number one that it is hard work and
that you work hard
hey on your bike no it's definitely hard
work but you know after the video came
out i decided to put out a dance fitness
workout called fade to fitness we have
different like dance workouts just to
make it easy because i know it's tough
like even with me
even though my body is the way it is or
how i look in front of people
i walk in the gym and i'm very
intimidated like that's why i don't work
out at the gym no
so i really get my body from dancing and
i toured pregnant until i was like five
months you know so
dancing played a big part in just me
period so
i wanted to find a balance to do fitness
and dance at the same time
because i energy all now one two
what's the one move though that women at
home can do like your favorite move that
you always do in your workout routines
and your exercises what's that
the hump on the floor from the interface
no i'm just playing dancing period
[Music]
though
you